carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
reciban un cordial saludo desde parís un
placer que estén nuevamente en nuestra
sintonía hoy los invitamos a conocer un
poco más del arte del tejido de la mano
de un artista joven que trabaja con los
hilos el color y la luz se llama kenia
almaraz murillo y está hoy en nuestros
estudios hola kenia para la maria de
carolina muchas gracias por recibirme
aquí no probó el is nuestro es el gusto
nuestro de recibirte aquí en carrusel de
las artes porque descubrí tu trabajo
hace poco y tenía muchas ganas de
invitarte para que nos hables de ese
arte que del que hemos hablado poco
nuestro programa el tejido y la pintura
que ni almaraz murillo hoy con nosotros
en carrusel de las artes
[Música]
nuestra invitada de hoy es un artista
que nos viene de bolivia ya nació en
santa cruz de la sierra y ahora vive y
trabaja en parís que en almaraz murillo
trabaja con las técnicas que se utilizan
en el tejido tradicional bolivia de
hecho tu país natal es un país conocido
por los tejidos tradicionales como los
aguayos pero tu kenia aunque tu familia
en tu familia se hace tejido tu
aprendiste a tejer aquí en francia sí
exactamente fue una gran historia en
realidad que no me esperaba hoy día
desarrollará este punto pero nací en
santa cruz que regrese yendo en los
tejidos en los colores en la geometría
en las líneas en los colores primarios
en las líneas horizontales bueno todo
ese atmósfera donde en el cual crecí
bueno creo que haga llevé conmigo en mi
corazón llegando aquí a francia y en la
edad era de esencia creo que poco a poco
fui captando a que la luz de este de
este continente de lo que veía y al
crecer contando esas dos esas dos
culturas de esos dos mundos bueno dieron
más lugares a tejidos con luces
mezclando material más natural de
producción más de vos
a lo que queda la tierra y bueno lo
mezclo como algo más tecnológico qué es
lo que se hace un poquito más del área
un poquito más electrónica y bueno son
los grandes puntos que hago mi trabajo y
ahora tú como en las comunidades
indígenas de bolivia o de los países
andinos utilizas el telar para para
hacer tus obras como lo hiciste que en
francia es decir conseguimos telares
aquí también en francia y tejido
tradicional como se hace en américa
latina la verdad que fue un gran
descubrimiento por mi parte porque yo
verdad que nunca imaginé algún día poder
aprender esa técnica porque verdad que
en familia se teje y siempre he crecido
con los pocos recuerdos que tengo de
niña de las abuelitas de mi abuelo de
mis tíos mi mamá que tejía y así
descubrió una gran gran cultura del
tejido aquí y fue un encuentro un poco
lo llama esto del destino porque es una
artista contemporánea que teje el metal
que bueno me enseñó aquí y dije cómo es
la vida no sea todo lo que no podríamos
aprender en la vida física con mi
familia lo aprendí aquí en el otro lado
del continente y del mundo pero con otra
otra pero en realidad son los mismos
lenguajes son las mismas técnicas son
los mismos las mismas máquinas y los
pocos imágenes que ha enviado del telar
es aquí es que el que tengo y
actualmente viene de una ciudad que se
llama opuso que es en la ciudad del
tejido tradicional aquí en francia y es
un gran honor para mí tener un telar tan
grande porque tienen tiene tiene edad
tiene un siglo y medio y cuando lo
comparo le envió fotos imágenes a mi
familia me dicen ah pero tenemos el
mismo con eso teníamos nosotros la
abuelita te y así y bueno realmente son
las mismas máquinas y los mismos códigos
solamente diferentes lenguajes pero
igual conectados y ahora en el tejido
tradicional tú lo decías hay muchos
colores hay formas geométricas pero tú
utilizas otros motivos sexo más de
paisajes de animales exactamente en
realidad creo que lo que más me cautivó
cuando descubrió los aguayos hechos por
mis abuelitos y mi abuelito fue que el
lado más geométrico y los colores vivos
que lo que me captaron más y cuando
viene aquí que estaba como llena que
quería expresar esas contemplaciones que
tenía eso en esos momentos en cuales
contemplaba un animal o iba un paisaje
en particular o sea la cosa de la
historia fue que cada vez que voy a
bolivia
es como si descubrieron más de mi país
más de donde vengo yo más de mis raíces
más de mi historia personal y sobre todo
la esta gran historia que esta cultura
increíble y cada día estoy agradecida
decime pero que qué maravillosa
oportunidad de haber nacido en este país
en esta ciudad y bueno esas
contemplaciones fuertes que tengo trato
de bueno de donde era un poco abstracta
figurar los como vibraciones vibraciones
de colores de motivo todo lo que se
repiten los aguayos tradicionales como
la mitología inca los halos con dos las
llamas las miradas eso de mi manera me
lo captó como una vibración es abstracta
y lo identificó como tipo diseños que se
acerca un poquito más a la chakana que
es un símbolo andino y escocesa un poco
abstracta pero siempre geométrica y
simétrica que acompaña una mirada por
ejemplo las luces vienen a completarse
como una mirada como dos puntos de luz
eso los redondos significan las lunas
los soles las líneas horizontales son
las líneas de los horizontes y todo lo
que es línea vertical en mi tejido
funciona como una
y es lo que se conoce más los tejidos de
las comunidades bolivianas el hecho que
el tejido con líneas horizontales
representa el campo la selva la
naturaleza y las líneas verticales
significa que es la acción del hombre y
bueno trato un poco colaborar y buscar
en la armonía en esos dos mundos sí
porque tú en tus obras aparte de los
hilos las líneas de hilos que hacen que
se hacen en el tejido has introducido
lámparas de leer luces piezas de madera
es como si quisieras tejer la luz o la
naturaleza quisiera estar en tu tejido
exactamente creo que es como siempre lo
digo es como un honor un homenaje a cada
ser vivo de bueno de madera personal es
como agradecerle a la tierra de esta
belleza que queda constantemente esta
abundancia esta generosidad y tejer la
luz es como si te dijeran las estrellas
conectando la directamente con esta esta
área aterra neal que esos son los seres
vivos y por eso que cada tejido que hago
es un homenaje a la a
y cada nombre que lleva cada tejido es
como si fuera una identidad única al
animal y trata un poco más
de meter a la luz como ese tejerla a la
luz la energía que el animal da digamos
o el paisaje y es por eso que
últimamente he estado trabajando sobre
leyendas urbanas también como el guajo
hou que es una leyenda típica de santa
cruz y en realidad siempre lo hemos
visto como una leyenda un poquito
nocturna que da miedo pero esta vez dije
pero quisiera conocer más a este pájaro
realidad cuál es su historia descubrió
un montón de belleza sobre cada animal y
sus plumas y bueno en la vida ese es el
proceso de creación creo que al ruedas
para mí es un gran honor de poder
digamos dar homenaje o agradecer a la
tierra haciendo aparecer eso esas
creaciones y en esa serie que nos
pudiste mostrar cuando fuimos a tu
taller eso eran creo 12 cuadros pero no
son sólo hilos también los pintas
también hay luz también hay planos de
hilos que sé que es que sé cómo que son
líneas de hilos cuéntanos cómo y están
colocados sobre sobre madera
en una parte antes de tejer en la
técnica del tejido comencé mi historia
pintando y fuese con la técnica de
serigrafía y después cuando entré a las
bellas artes en la escuela aquí en parís
este comencé a desarrollar en la pintura
al óleo y en realidad cuando siempre en
5 años de estudio siempre he hecho
pintura al óleo en la escuela y tejido
al exterior y bueno dije el momento pero
cuánto cuánto quisiera juntar esas dos
técnicas que tanto he desarrollado
separar separadamente así quedan más
plazo le digo a este lugar al volumen y
ahí bueno aplicó estructuras donde
mezcló pec siglas con madera basado como
tipo una estructura de un telar y ahí
éste pongo mis y los verticales y en vez
de tejer no tejo y en vez de pintar no
pinto o sea pongo mis líneas en lanas
rectas verticales y vengo a pintar en
horizontal con la serigrafía y esa es
una fusión que finalmente dan más
esculturas en volumen casi simétrico y
en realidad son composiciones que se
hacen geométricamente pero por nivel
el hilo es pintado pintado manualmente y
así subo de nivel y en realidad se hace
se vuelve un poco a pintar los hilos
digo es como pintar al óleo en realidad
estoy pintando una tela o sea siempre es
un poco basado de esas ganas de pintar
pintar la trama como se dice y bueno fue
eso de saber ser un poco otro medio que
nace también y en esa época bueno buena
instalación y bueno desarrollo de nuevos
universos y escuchándote hablar
escuchándote describir tu obra
pienso en que finalmente los tejidos en
bolivia tienen tiene una utilidad se
utilizan para llevar a los niños para
cubrirse para para rituales tú has
sacado tutu vamos a decir sus formatos
tus obras salen de esa funcionalidad
para convertirse en obras de arte si de
cierta gente bueno la verdad que fue un
como una experiencia increíble que fue
muy experimentar al principio y es lo
que digo lo que descubro cada vez con la
historia no no he llegado a un punto
donde digo wow lo sé todo al contrario
me encanta descubrir cada cara cada
época cada obra cada pieza tiene su vida
hacia historia y a la base justamente
los tejidos los aguayos eran eran son
creados para rituales para eventos
específicos algo algo bien sagrado es
como una contemplación una meditación
una conexión con más allá y es lo que
más este es el lado filo es el lado
espiritual lo que más me ha captado yo
creo inconscientemente porque cada
proceso de cada tejido que hago no es un
simple tejido de realidad es una
historia personal una conexión un
agradecimiento es cada cada piscina que
tiene su tiempo y su función y al final
una vez que ya nace es como si me
pondría un poco arrodillarme decirle
gracias por existir y en realidad es ese
este típico personal que lo hago esa es
la experiencia finalmente es como tipo
un ritual y por eso es que digo cada
pieza tiene su lugar y cada cada tienen
su energía y su vida propia
me imagino además que como cada obra
implican semanas incluso meses de
trabajo porque es línea por línea que se
hace que se construye el tejido es una
actividad que te permite esa
contemplación esa meditación de la que
hablas
la realidad que digo es que una vez que
estamos en los hilos ya no pierden
noción del tiempo todos todos y pierde
claro estoy consciente que estoy viva
que estén en este en este cuerpo que
estoy activa pero al final creo que no
solamente se vuelve energía es por eso
que el tiempo ya no cuenta o sea puede
llevar una semana puede llevar un mes
puede llevar meses depende de cada
acción y cada línea que se teje cada
ganas que tengo que meterle otra otro
elemento y otro elemento y como ahora
trabajo con artesanos y también
ingenieros de luces para un poco más
llevar a cabo algunas algunos tejidos
bueno toma su tiempo y el tiempo ya no
existe en realidad es por eso que
llamamos justamente el hecho de tejer es
para mí como un viaje un poco astral que
haces entre dos épocas dos tiempos dos
mundos diferentes dos países y eso lo
que permite juntar a la como se dice el
hilo vertical como el y horizontal y
crear esa trama universal y bueno es así
que lo veo un poco en el tejido de
oralidad pasa más que sólo el lado
artesanal es algo simbólicamente en
poderoso y para mí es un honor poder
completar ese aprecio aprendizaje porque
va a ser toda mi vida que voy a aprender
cada vez cosas más y me permite conectar
más con mi bolivia con mi historia
personal y con la de familia y descubrir
un montón de historias y riquezas
maravillosas este país y bueno esa es mi
historia y ha venido además a visitarnos
hoy
peinada con un atuendo muy bonito muy
colorido dorado y rojo muchísimas
gracias kenia por haber estado con
nosotros el día de hoy y vamos a
terminar esta plática
presentándole a nuestros oyentes y
televidentes un videoclip una obra que
hiciste en compañía de otro artista que
se llama elliot cost para la sala de
cine huyese leal aquí en parís
fluctuación es el clip el nombre de esta
canción con la que despedimos nuestro
programa muchísimas gracias a todos por
habernos recibido en sus casas y hasta
la próxima
[Música]
con tarifa de esa línea con la cosa sale
pastilla se hizo se parten el mundo
cambia y sombras
[Música]
sin ideas
los ojos 8 de diferido colo colo hace 36
meses
[Música]
no